what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 2 of our deep learning with
neural networks tensorflow and python
tutorial and also part pro 44 I think in
the machine learning tutorial series so
this part this this tutorial is going to
be pretty optional so because it's so
specific this is we're just going to be
installing tensorflow on a virtual
machine you don't have to install
tensorflow on a virtual machine if you
already have an ubuntu machine or you're
on mac great you can just install it
straight onto your Mac you're good if
you already have a server or something
you want to run with install it on your
server that's really fun this is just
for people with Windows machines
basically okay so or someone who wants
to use a virtual machine either one
anyway so if you get a tensorflow
website you can just go to the get
started I suppose these first few steps
but you should be able to figure this
out but anyway discipline org get
started and then you look download and
setup ok these are the requirements that
you have and then there's all these
other things here we are going to be
installing the CPU version of tensorflow
we might touch on GPU enable down the
line at something I want to get into so
I might do something but something tells
me that's going to be of even more
specific than this is and it can get
hairy but I'll probably do it anyway
just because I'm interested in that but
for to start the CPU versions much
easier we don't have to install CUDA we
don't have to make sure everyone's CUDA
enabled and that would probably kick out
quite a few of you so anyways we're just
gonna use a CPU version to start now
again there is nothing for Windows you
can use docker I don't know much about
docker but I like a boon to and if I'm
going to actually do machine learning to
scale
chances are I'm doing that somewhere in
the cloud and I'm going to be on a bun
too so or some Linux distribution so I
figure I'm just going to do that I could
be totally wrong and that sort of logic
and reasoning this whole kind of field
of machine learning and to scale and all
that is still relatively new who knows
what kind of platform people are going
to be doing this on as things progress
so do whatever you want I'm not
advocating that this is the best way
this is just the way I've chosen to do
it so yeah so you can do a pip install
it's super simple
you can do a bunch of stuff and first
what we're going to do is get the
virtual machine get a boon to on the
virtual machine and then we're going to
install tensorflow so first we're going
to go to virtualbox.org and then you can
go slash wiki slash downloads and then
go to the downloads page and download
whatever one matches what you're trying
to do now I'm on 64-bit windows so I
would take this download right and it
starts this download here so whenever
that's done you open up VirtualBox
honestly I think VirtualBox was like
super simple to setup but I'm still
going to run through the setup just
because it's so simple it's very quick
while we're waiting on that actually
that's basically done so cool alright so
I'm going to click on that let that come
up here cool next everything looks good
there
yeah next don't like to clutter my stuff
we'll keep that file associations
because they make VirtualBox has like a
special partition on your hard drive so
it's kind of useful to know what the
hell that partition is so I'll leave
that there
this just tells you that you might
disconnect I actually have never
disconnected while doing this but anyway
so we begin the installation and we're
good to go while we're waiting on that
installation I'm just gonna move this
and the next thing sorry I don't know if
I get cut out or what I got a little
admin thing pop-up anyway the next thing
that we're going to need is a boon to so
I'm going to open up a new tab here and
whoops that's my tutorial all right
so you go to a boon to calm and then
download and then I use the alternative
downloads because it was a lot quicker
so you can go to I'm using the desktop
version as well but anyway you can go
download and you would probably want to
be into desktop you could just do a boon
to server and I think that's just had
licit just doesn't have the GUI you know
X but I think the GUI desktop is kind of
useful at least when you're playing
around in doing development I don't
prefer to be headless if I don't have to
but the desktop does take up processing
and also space so you could you could
elect to just have a server if you
wanted but anyway
Lubuntu desktop let's say that's the one
you want all
a new tab boom and you can download from
here now it's a fairly large image
you're downloading the ISO you can also
donate and stuff like that but I'm
actually not going to not even going to
download well I'm gonna start the
download probably uh but anyway it's
actually really really slow it's 1.4
gigabytes and it's a slow download but
if you go to the alternative downloads
we want in my blind now 1604 60 I'm I
want 64-bit this is another kind of
point of contention that or a point of
problem I'm assuming most people on
modern computers today are running
64-bit you want 64-bit so your
applications can use more than 2
gigabytes of memory so you want 64-bit
now I will just say because I probably
forget later on but hopefully when I'm
setting it up I'll remember to just
because your 64-bit you download this
VirtualBox so your virtual machine your
computer by default most computers don't
actually allow for hardware
virtualization which you need to do
64-bit so you'll have to go into your
BIOS settings like when you restart your
computer you hit the Delete key to go
into BIOS and then you want to enable
Hardware virtual virtual ization and
that'll be under like a CPU section ok
so it has to do with your architecture
of your CPU let man or your CPU section
that's what 64-bit so anyway it'll be in
your CPU section just go into BIOS
sometimes will be like advanced CPU or
maybe you'll have like a CPU section
everyone's BIOS is a little different
but anyway if you want 64-bit that's
what you got to do so anyway I wanted
the 64-bit and what that does is you
download the torrent for that and you
can use something like utorrent or
something like that do the download and
it'll take like two minutes if you have
a decent connection rather than like an
hour ok so anyway pause the video make
sure you get this however you want to
get it if you just do the simple
download or if you have like utorrent or
something like that
you can download it really really quick
as long as you have a decent connection
so anyways you'll download Ubuntu and I
forget where I've been
let me check to make sure I haven't been
to in a proper location
we'll see it I guess I'll see oh yeah I
have it okay cool okay so anyways
download them into and then we'll
proceed to the next step so looks like
we're here so the installation is
complete start oracle virtualbox great
so I hit finished there and then here we
are brand new VirtualBox this is
unbelievably stupid simple but cool so
we'll go ahead and hit new because we
want to make a new virtual machine so
new and then we can call this whatever
we want I'll call this tensorflow Tut's
okay and then the type is going to be
Linux and then we're going to be we're
running a boom to 64-bit so you click
this drop down 64-bit if you click that
drop down and you don't see 64-bit
you're like what gives you have to
enable hardware virtualization in your
BIOS do that and then this option will
appear if you don't do that that option
is probably not there for you so anyway
do that I guess you won't be able to
pause the video until you that would
restart going to your BIOS enable
hardware virtualization great hit next
okay here's where you decide how much
memory this virtual machine is going to
take up now this is not memory that's
going to be taken up all of the time
it's just while the virtual machine is
running so I have apparently total of
like 32 gigabytes of RAM so I you know I
might want to allocate I don't know
whatever you might want to stick with
like 8192 like 8 gigs of RAM or you
could even go even harder and do like
kind of twelve or sixteen I think I'll
go ahead and do sixteen if I recall I
didn't have issues with RAM the biggest
issue because as you'll see uh this
isn't an obviously this kind of machine
isn't enough to run huge and also we
were just talking about data sizes
earlier we're sucking like you know you
might run petabytes worth of data how
the heck would you put that much data
into memory so anyways we'll talk about
that later but you can run it in batches
so anyways I'll give it 16 I really want
this to be perfect
I guess that is it okay anyway about 16
gigs of ram great then you have harder
or hard-disk uh you do want to create a
hard disk now it says the recommended
size is 8 gigabytes don't do 8 gigabytes
so just click next we'll stick with VDI
next um you can go dynamically allocated
or the fixed size you should pick a
fixed size dynamically allocated sounds
great but the input-output speed can be
significantly hindered with dynamically
allocated which can be really annoying
so just go with the fixed size hit next
and then don't do 8 gigabytes um I'm
pretty sure with 8 gigabytes you won't
even be able to install Kubuntu 1604 64
bit that's not even enough space at
least the desktop version it'll just
fail so give yourself probably more like
50 or even a hundred or something like
that give yourself a decent amount
let me check to make sure my main drives
a solid state and I don't have a ton of
memory space and in fact I bet some is
not even cleared up I don't even know
where that goes off to look for that
later I should have a lot more space but
I think some is being held by another
virtual machine anyway when you make
this it's going to take up that man
remember how it's saying like the RAM so
I'm going to be using your RAM on the
virtual boxes off but it's going to be
using your your storage right it's going
to use your hard drive space it's just
going to make a flat file that's that
size so I guess we'll stick with I think
50 gigabytes I'll be fine I just don't
wanna run out of space anyway
I think I have another one I can delete
but anyway 50 gigabytes about should be
good so that's going to take a little
bit depending if you have a solid state
that should go pretty quick if you have
like a regular hard drive that might
take like 10 times as long so I don't
know mindset is about a minute so let's
talk about some of the other stuff we're
going to do once this is done we'll be
ready to basically start installing
tensorflow there's not too much going on
as far as what's left actually to cover
I might pause here I don't know
everyone's gotta wait this one minute so
I don't know at least but um see a few
of the things that we're going to do
once we create this you can also for
some reason when you're setting it up
you choose your your memory you choose
your hard drive but you do not choose
how many CPU cores you're going to
dedicate to or CPUs you're going to
dedicate to this virtual machine so
we're going to change that
there's also trying to think there
anything else I can't really think of
anything else I think I'm gonna have to
pause this well while I wait so go ahead
and just pause this and then we're going
so the rest of stuff I can't really talk
about until we actually get there all
right we are back I finally finished
we've got our machine here it's just
prepared to accept a boon to but we
haven't actually got up into setup here
yet but the first thing we're actually
gonna do is right-click and go to
settings there we are and I'm trying to
think where I want to go so first of all
if you take a snapshot it'll go here and
a snapshots just a way to like back up
your machine hopefully you won't need to
do that there's not enough like settings
involved here you really just have a
script and then you might have some data
that you want to save but you can't
imagine why you at this stage would need
to make backups but anyway popping into
system I'm sorry I'm just trying to find
a processor here we go so system we're a
motherboard here go to processor the
default is to give you one CPU well most
modern processors are going to have at
least four with like hyper threading I
think it's called a camera you should
get like eight if you have four core for
core anyway um we're gonna I'm going to
bump this up to eight kill my computer
otherwise but that's okay the only time
I'm going to be using this is when I'm
like running stuff or working on it and
I don't need all of my cores so I always
will go with 8 at any time you can just
like lower this is not a big deal so
cool the other thing we're going to do
is go to acceleration
and nope that's not what I'm looking for
let's go down to display then okay cool
video memory so if you want to allocate
some video memory it shouldn't make a
huge difference but your you want to
give it some video memory just so it has
some some capabilities I'll give it like
a hundred then monitor account however
many monitors you want them surprised it
knows eight I have four monitors now so
you could in theory like give your
actual have five I guess you could give
it a more monitors but I'm not sure why
you'd want to do that and then if you
can you might want to enable 3d
acceleration and I think that's all I
want to do here it's got a general real
quick let's go basic somewhere in here
you can say where your hmm where your
your ISO is but I'm not seeing it here
but that's okay
I didn't this isn't the original way I
did it anyway I think that's all we want
to do let's hit okay right
okay now power this thing on let's just
double click it and that kind of powers
it on and hopefully it'll tell us so you
don't have a thing right empty so mine
is going to be in downloads let's see
let me pull up give all my vacation
pictures out of downloads for I make
mistake here gosh I deleted the great
fantastic alright cool
anyway so I deleted the the ISO fabulous
okay anyway let's open this up great now
the only thing in downloads is that so
there's the image it's in mine was in
downloads but yours might be somewhere
else bang on how you download it or
whatever where your torrents go
so yeah cool open that and so now we
have the disk that we want we'll go
ahead and hit start and
apparently it starts virtual machine you
get this message and just close this out
little lovely purple for a boon to wait
for it a lot of times I see a really
nasty message but I'm not seeing it yet
but we'll see so then we run through
like the aboon to set up okay
since this tutorial is so specific I'm
gonna just keep filming as I set this up
because hopefully anybody that's so
following to this point it's doing
exactly this thing but anyway so we want
to install the boon - we don't want to
just try it we will download the updates
while we install we don't need third
parties stuff hit continue okay so this
is a little uncomfortable but this is
what you want to do okay you want to
erase the disk and install the boon -
alright this because it's on a virtual
machine it's just that little virtual
disk okay so it's not going to do so I'm
going to clear out your main computer
but this is pretty uncomfortable to do
but anyway yeah so erase disk and
continue install that um yep great
deletes everything tutorial cuts out
I don't yeah fine Chicago that's cool
English yes please let's continue your
name we'll just call this TF Tut's cool
um I'm not going to put it password on
this I don't think yeah I'm not gonna
I'm so uncomfortable not putting a
password on things I'll do it so you can
put a password I'll I think will encrypt
the home folder hopefully that's not
going I don't think that would have any
effect on that 10th floor and now we
wait for the install go faster
Wow this is taking forever my goodness
so once we get it installed
unfortunately we do have a few things we
need to install tensorflow but the
actual tensorflow install is that is
really quick
but we also want to run a command that
will let us have a resizable screen like
right now you resize the screen and it
stays the same size why is this still
like not moving I might pause it because
I'm pro okay so say my pause that's not
normal for it to just like freeze up
like that but anyway apparently it's it
was working and it's almost done I don't
know umm yeah great anyways so we'll run
a command that will let us resize other
than that we will just be installing
tensorflow and then we'll be done we'll
test the tensorflow install of course oh
and also I'm going to put on sublime
text I don't know if I want to do that
in this tutorial or the next one though
but that's the editor I'm going to use
is sublime oh he's using a different
editor than idle whoa honestly I'm just
doing it because I have no idea I don't
even know how you'd get idle on it boon
to fix it wasn't it's not there by
default even though python 3 is so it
just I just use sublime ok I'm going to
pause again wow this installs I will see
you guys when your installation is
complete so whenever your installation
is complete like press pause and then
whenever it's complete our resume
alright so the installation is complete
you can click restart now
you can give it a second to attempt to
restart from every time I've ever
installed anything well at least in
Ubuntu
it doesn't actually restart it's
probably cuz it's a virtual machine or
something and the restart doesn't seem
to work I don't know anyway we'll wait a
sec
so yeah nothing really seems to work so
I'm going to just right-click on the
virtual machine here and just hit reset
hopefully that'll do something something
good for us we'll see all right
so okay let's make a big screen now and
if you've opted for a password go ahead
type that in and we'll wait wait okay
great so a shortcut to the terminal is
ctrl alt T hit that in this little box
should come up for you the first thing
we're going to do is give us the ability
to resize because as you start to code
and do stuff you kind of want to have it
be able to be full screens so you can go
to the text-based version of this
tutorial and get this command or you can
just type it out with me but it's sudo
apt-get install virtualbox - guests -
utils VirtualBox - guest - X 11 and
VirtualBox - guests - DKMS I'm just
checking and looks good let's do it
yes and when this is done we can run a
reboot and hopefully it will be able to
be full screen
it's telling us about software updates
hopefully I mean we should have run the
updates as we installed so I don't know
why it's telling us that the other thing
we might as well do while we're waiting
on that is go to its plumb texture
yeah sublime text calm I'll close this
out so blaim text calm and I'll just
make a big screen I'll go to download
and we'll download the 64 bit dot Deb
save cool so this will be at UM C open
containing folder okay yeah like home
downloads and then that file so keep
that in mind for a minute we can close
out of the Firefox now we're all done
okay so let's go ahead and install this
real quick so whenever you get that
Debian file the way that you're going to
do this now is sudo what is it it'll be
sudo d PKG i and then home slash
downloads and then it was sublime
something Deb cool okay and then
whenever you're done with that the next
thing that we need to run is going to be
sudo apt-get install - f:o installed a
chef great now hopefully like if we go
right click new folder tensorflow
tights just make it quick
yeah new document and we'll just call it
a
TF basics dot hi interesting open with
yeah we could open it with sublime
should like have a Python logo but
anyway okay cool so we've got sublime
and all that I guess we'll go ahead and
do the Google thing I mean might as well
while we're here the other thing I might
do see if I can I guess I can't really
make this text any bigger but yeah if
you if you can't read this tech the
sublime text I'll make big enough so
it's really clear but for some reason I
can't make this text any any larger so
if we go to and in fact let's go ahead
and just reboot this that way we can be
full screen for the next part because
you're gonna have to reboot it at some
point so let's just go and reset it it's
usually pretty quick to reset anyway and
hopefully it'll be full screen when it
resets this time yes great alright now
we have the full screen you can even
actually go even more like you can have
it truly be full screen by going at full
screen mode but sometimes it's kind of
annoying to get out of it so I don't
really like it anyway so now what we're
going to do is we're going to go to
tensorflow org or is it tensor yeah
tensor flow org and then finally we get
to install so get started the PIP
installation and so these are the
instructions we're just going to run
them so first we'll run this ctrl T for
the terminal paste so we run that yes
and obviously if you're on Mac you'd run
those other things I don't think anybody
with Mac is still watching however
shouldn't be and then and then pay
attention here because these are all the
like options well we're running Python
3.5 and in fact we probably didn't even
need to run these things cuz we actually
don't need we need Python 3 dad - dev
and Python 3 tip we should actually have
all those things but maybe not
anyway this tutorial is in Python 3 not
Python 2 and this is for Python 2 anyway
so do Python 3 rather and then coming
down here we want the CPU only version
for python 3.5 again later on we might
do the GPU version but GP requires the
cool CUDA toolkit and cadena and all
these other things that complicates
things that we don't need at the moment
so anyway to get regular we do this copy
that line for 64-bit Linux if you're on
32 of us to get the 32 CPU only 3.5
great coming over here right click paste
wow that was quick surely that worked
anyway and then because all that's doing
is just putting the link to tensorflow
for us so I guess it should be quick
sudo pip 3 install - - upgrade and then
dolla sign TF underscore binary
underscore URL hopefully we didn't
actually need the upgrades we don't
actually have this installed but that's
ok
so while that's installing basically
when that's done we're done because
we've got sublime to write the code we
got tensorflow
so yeah we're all set so let's make sure
this worked where am i typing just type
Python 3 and then do import tensorflow
as TF great so as long as that works you
are now ready to go to the next tutorial
where we're going to talk about the
tensorflow basics
just kind of how it works and then after
that we're going to start building our
own neural networks so anyways that's
what you have to look forward to if you
for some reason
using this method can't get tensorflow
installed I can do my best to help you
out but there's like a billion ways to
install tensorflow so that's why this
was kind of optional but anyways there
we have it we're ready to rhumble so
till next time